when we go
all the way to
understanding what our
truest essence
is
it gives us the insight
that life
is a processing system
life is
an exploration of possibility and
where is the exploration
of possibility happening
it's happening via us
we are the units
the sensors the observers
the witnesses the consciousness the
awareness that is able to
process life
we are that which enables
the exploration of this possibility
so you go all the way to the most
essential nature of what we are
and you realize out of the boundless
space of infinite possibility
that this universe is a manifestation
of an exploration
of possibility and life
is the processing system
that is that which comprehends that
which interprets that which explores and
plays
of what this universe was manifested for
it was manifested for exploring a
possibility of
unbounded potential and life is that
which comprehends
the possibility life is that which
explores
and plays the possibility space
when you view life as a decentralized
processing system
what you do is you shift your identity
from being
a centralized entity that is separate
from all other centralized entities that
you have
no relationship to but rather the entire
universe becomes your
body so
you no longer have a firm
wall of separation but instead
what you have is a very porous
very frictionless
very formless interconnectedness and
interdependence to all of life
you become identified as life itself you
become identified as the entire
processing system that is the universe
so if you
take your identity from what was this
conditioned subconscious
separate finite biological entity
and in the process of awakening you
absolutely
burst out of that little contracted
identity to identifying yourself
as all the way to
the most fundamental essence which is
the very source of infinite possibility
unbounded potential that you'll never
come to the end to
which is again eternity
therefore this universe
is
you appearing as
the processing of
potentiality the universe is the
processing of potentiality
and you've decentralized your identity
to where
you are the universe processing
potentiality
you are life itself processing
potentiality
and so because of that there's a
very profound shift
you're no longer identified as
a conditioned separate entity
but you're now identified as the very
source of
infinite possibility itself that has
manifested an exploration
of possibility and is using
life as the very processing
system
to understand that possibility
to comprehend that possibility
so another way of saying it is that life
is that which
comprehends potentiality
life is that which comprehends
potentiality
again do your best to get out of the
separate identity
to identifying as life itself as the
universe itself because if you can get
to that
stage you can really start tapping into
the unity and the oneness of life
being the processing system
and your identity being that whole life
as a processing system rather than being
just
a separate entity
once you become more
awake to
infinite possibility being explored
using universes and consciousness
and life as a processing system
you then
become more aware of what
is the essential nature of reality
and you relax away any tensions
and you become more
purely of a shepherd
for the rest of life to awaken to this
realization
so you have this absolute
unbounded infinitude of possibility
and then you have the universe as a
manifestation
of exploring
a lot of possibility
and you have life acting as the
comprehension
system the processing system
of all of that potentiality that has
manifested
in this universe
and i remember there was a viewer that
was coming to our channel
quite a bit and was mentioning this
perpetually that life is a processing
system
and it was slowly landing more and more
in my heart as i was awakening but most
recently as my identity has been just so
decentralized that i finally really
experientially understood what that
viewer was perpetually saying
by articulating that life is a
processing system
and i'm really grateful for you thank
you for perpetually saying that
and i hope that the
realization
ends up opening higher possibilities for
you right now
all of these viewers
because that is what
ultimately life wants to do for itself
life wants to help awaken
itself to its truest nature
but the entire game that life plays
that infinity plays with itself using
life
as the processing system is
falling asleep to itself
so that it can then undergo the process
of awakening
to itself
this might be one of the most important
realizations
period
because when you understand your truest
nature
as absolute infinity
total indescribable unboundedness
and you recognize that the universe is a
manifestation
of life
processing
a tremendous amount
of that possibility space
you're able to relax away any of the
conditioned tensions of separation
that are subconsciously running
your life seeking
validation or worthiness
or money or fame or clout
or relationships or experiences
because you recognize that the entirety
of your truest nature is already
always totally free
whole complete enlightened
always forever
you have to remember that infinity's
essence is that it always knows itself
but that it undergoes a process of
veiling itself at the same time it
always knows itself but it also veils
itself and awakens via these processing
systems
unbounded potentiality
in using the universe and
life as a processing system of
a tremendous amount of that potentiality
you are always never in a cage
you are always never in a cage but yet
you undergo the illusion of putting
yourself
into an asleep in cage and then breaking
yourself
out of that in order to awaken to your
truest infinite nature
cool life as a processing system hope
this was
insightful valuable if so let me know in
the comments below with where you're at
like the video subscribe if you haven't
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would be impactful
for watching that's all
infinite love decentralize that identity
baby
see life as a processing system of
infinite potential
comprehending such a tremendous amount
of the space of potentiality
thank you
you